>>Reto Meier: Good afternoon everyone and
welcome to this Friday's edition of The Friday
App Clinic.
Today we're looking at finance apps.
My name's Reto.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I'm Ian.
>>Reto Meier: And hopefully we're gonna be
able to provide some advice as to how you
can take your finance app and make it all
the better.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And in honor of finance app
week, instead of beer, today we're drinking
Hendricks's dry martinis.
>>Reto Meier: Very nice.
Keeping it classy.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Two olives and a Spanish caper.
>>Reto Meier: Wow, taking note at home I hope.
So I tried to find the richest person I knew
and the closest I could come was Ian who does
drive a BMW.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's true, my wife bought
it.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
That'll work.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It makes me rich in two ways.
>>Reto Meier: Awe.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Awe.
>>Reto Meier: I hope she's watching at home
so you'll get full credit for that.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Of course she's not watching
at home she'd be watching at work.
>>Reto Meier: That would make a lot of sense.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
So, right, we took a look at several financial
apps that we're
>>Reto Meier: Yep.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: of course, suggested by viewers.
Now, we weren't able to look at all of them
and part of the reason is that financial apps,
by their very nature, can ask for some sensitive
information and neither one of us were comfortable
giving our bank accounts to a third party.
>>Reto Meier: This is true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Which, uh, actually when you
think about it is a little silly, maybe.
>>Reto Meier: Possibly.
And certainly some of the apps, I think Mint
in particular was one app which has gotten
huge reviews, it's an editor's choice, it's
by all counts very trustworthy and a very
high quality app.
So in a way I felt like people have already
looked at this thing and said how great it
is so we can probably skip it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Point of fact, we have already
looked at it
>>Reto Meier: It's true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: and worked with a team.
We loved it.
I've seen it in beta.
But, yeah, I didn't, it's not so much I didn't
wanna trust Mint with my credentials, I just
didn't wanna show everybody my financial statements
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: On air.
Reto Meier: That's a fair call.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, the sheer amount of
beer budget
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think would have really
boggled people's minds.
>>Reto Meier: Mm, yeah, you don't want to
shock anyone too dramatically.
So, yeah, that makes sense.
Sadly, neither of us has a Cayman Islands
account that we can use to just, you know,
demonstrate how it would work.
So you'll have to try that yourselves at home.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But what we do have is brand
new microphones and a couple new cameras today.
>>Reto Meier: That's true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So before we get into we just
wanna show stuff off.
We're on the new microphones which are high
quality microphones as opposed to the ones
we got on like Amazon or Overstock sale for
like 400 bucks for 4 of them.
>>Reto Meier: Which is
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It was 400 for 8 now that
I think about it.
>>Reto Meier: This is good news for the local
Karaoke team who will really enjoy being able
to use those mics.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
So if you have any comments about the sound
quality just keep them to yourself today.
We don't wanna hear it.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Just kidding.
Daniel Pham, our engineer, is looking out
for sound quality but if he misses anything
just let us know.
Speaking of Daniel Pham, let's switch over
to the engineer cam!
Woo!
Engineer cam!
>>Daniel Pham: I don't have one yet.
Later, guys.
>>Reto Meier: Later guys, alright.
No engineer cam quite yet.
I saw it move.
You can see engineer cam right there.
>>Daniel Pham: Hi guys!
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's right; we moved the
lights after we set up engineer cam.
>>Daniel Pham: Yeah, it's right up in my face.
I'm gonna move over.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Nice.
>>Reto Meier: Perfect.
We have the sun in the studio now so we're
hoping to get some better light quality as
well.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed, although I think we
are still getting this
[Inaudible]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's alright.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so let's
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Let's move on.
>>Reto Meier: Let's get slightly less meta
and have a look at some apps.
So, we've got a few.
We're gonna try to get through as many of
these as we can and they represent quite a
varied, a large variation in app types I think
is fair to say.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I think, you know, we
talked about financial apps and I think our
viewers took that a lot of different ways.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Everything from Amp Sale to
IOU to Fat Mole Free.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Which I noticed you have installed.
Maybe you didn't realize that it's all about
managing your finances.
This is sort of a metaphor.
>>Reto Meier: Ah, that's interesting.
Yeah, I did see the game and I thought, "This
is a game, why is it in my app review?"
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well if you think of it as
a game
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: In the same way that life
is a game.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, in fact, it's disappointing
that no one's nominated the game online cause
I guess that would have been an interesting
opportunity.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
So why don't we take a short look at AppSavings.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: This is, I guess it's financial
in a way but not quite the way we were thinking.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, it's about saving money,
I suppose, rather than managing your finances.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Reto Meier: Which is totally legitimate.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So this is kind of an interesting,
we think that it might skirt the line on Google
Playstore policy.
So, what it does is it tracks the prices of
apps on the Google Playstore so that you can
be notified if something goes on sale.
>>Reto Meier: Very nice.
It has a nice UI.
Fairly straight forward using an action bar,
it's not actually an action bar it's more
of a pseudo action bar but, you know, that's
okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know we're seeing a lot
of this, Reto; we're seeing a lot of fake
action bars, why do you think that is?
>>Reto Meier: Probably because there's no
framework way of being able to have action
bars for devices running new, old versions
of Android.
[Inaudible due to audio]
>>Reto Meier: I think the,
[Cannot understand due to audio]
>>Reto Meier: It does provide something that
is very authentic and gives you that ability.
With that said, I think what's happening in
this app, here, is totally legitimate.
It is an, it is an action bar, it works the
way that you would expect it to.
The only feedback I'd give in this particular
instance is to be careful about the icons,
the style of the icons that you're using.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: So, in this case they're using,
sort of, the themed icons so that they, sort
of, faded into the action bar itself.
It's an interesting approach but that's immediately
what makes it obvious that this isn't, you
know, a standard action bar.
I would have a look at the design side and
stick to the design guidelines in terms of
your icons.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
This is, I think, what we've said over and
over is that if you have a great design idea
that doesn't fit into our design guidelines,
by all means use it.
But, if you're trying to mimic something that
the Android design guidelines already covered
and it looks enough like a standard Android
feature that people might think it is then
don't make it work differently and preferably
don't make it look particularly different.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
I think that's the key here.
If you wanna do something radically different
then that's a fantastic idea, I mean, we love
to see really innovative designs.
But if you're doing something which is supposed
to, which looks like an action bar or any
other sort of system element, it should behave
the same way and it should look as close to
it as possible so you're not, sort of, getting
thrown.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
Now, speaking of icons, I think that's actually
my biggest concern about this app because
I should say right off the top, I love this
app.
>>Reto Meier: It's a great app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I love the fact that this
app exists, I love the idea behind it but
there is one thing that I am concerned about
and that is that the app is using these icons
which represent each of the applications.
Now, those applications have uploaded icons
to the Google Playstore and given Google permission
to use that artwork.
And their artwork does actually belong to
the people who have created the application.
>>Reto Meier: Very true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, to the people that made
AppSales, um, the one thing that I would wanna
be sure of, and of course I have no idea,
but in general you wanna make sure that you
have negotiated the rights to these icons
before you use them because you don't necessarily
have permission to use them in this context.
>>Reto Meier: That's right.
And in this instance, I imagine it's not gonna
be too hard to get that approval if you're
able to reach out because you're basically
helping people to sell their apps when they've
got them on sale.
So it's free advertising, but as Ian said,
just because it is definitely useful for them
doesn't mean that you automatically get the
right to use them.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yep.
>>Reto Meier: The other thing, which I'm gonna
look at, I'm not actually gonna click it because
then I will have seen something which can't
be unseen.
But, it implies here that perhaps this is
gonna link me to something which is not downloadable
from the Google Playstore which would be a
violation of the content policies which says
that you can't link to an external app store.
If you wanna have app downloads, it's gotta
be through Google Play.
So, I'm not gonna click it and that way I
won't know but if the developer of AppSales
is out there I would definitely look carefully
at that and make sure you're not violating
any of our policies.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
Okay, so I think that's all we need to say
about AppSales.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah I think that's all we need
to say.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think it's a really cool
idea.
>>Reto Meier: Definitely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Definitely just need to maybe
take care cause any time you get into app
information at all there's a bunch of twiddly
legal and policy issues that you really need
to take care of.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
It's a great idea and as an engineer I think
we can all get on board.
It's the, sort of thing we think, "Hey, this
would be really cool.
An app which tracks which apps are for sale,
that would be really useful."
And it is.
But then sadly the legal policy stuff gets
in the way and you kind of have to do your
due diligence to find out what you can in
content.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, you know what else would
be awesome?
>>Reto Meier: What's that?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Is just a site where I could
go and just find free movies.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then I would just download
that.
I would download them really fast.
>>Reto Meier: That would be useful, yes.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
>>Reto Meier: Also, possibly some legal complications
there.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Not everything we want to
have happen is legal in today's world.
Contact your representatives.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Uh, so, should we go to Timesheet?
>>Reto Meier: Let's check out Timesheet, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Let's fire it up here.
As you can probably see we have one of our
new cameras giving us a different view of
the phone cam.
So hopefully this is easy for everyone to
see at home and with 90 to 100 percent fewer
reflections.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: yes.
>>Reto Meier: So this is, this is kind of
an interesting app.
You know, those of you who, like me, has done
contract work in the past, or, you know, run
your own business, then the idea of having
to keep time sheets is as familiar as it is
frustrating.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I probably shouldn't admit
this but I had a dream a few nights ago where
you were chasing me around trying to fill
out a time sheet.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then you explained that
all time spent on personal calls could not
be included in my Google work day.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
That doesn't sound like something I would
do.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I need to see somebody.
>>Reto Meier: You do need to see somebody.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: I think next week we can have
self help apps.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
>>Reto Meier: That might help you out.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so, okay, so looking at
the app straight away, what I found kind of
interesting about this was the navigation,
I guess, was the problem to put it in a nutshell.
The look and feel is great; you've got the
action bar on the top using standard icons
you know exactly what's going on.
So the first time I, and I kinda like this
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: it's really cool, I like it.
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
It's in a nice sort of cursive font, sort
of giving you a hint as to what's going on.
So once you've got things set up that's fair
enough.
So we are in the app clinic, so I should start
working.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Still working on a task so you
can stop working, have a break, all these
sorts of things.
It does actually stick it into your ongoing
notifications so you can continue to do other
work.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, that's very cool.
>>Reto Meier: And you're notified when that's
happening.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, hang on, just a second.
Break.
[Pause]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, let's continue.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, let's continue.
Perfect.
So, now, interestingly we have to now put
in details
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Did I enjoy the break?
I did, actually.
It was quite refreshing.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
And, save.
So, this is interesting.
So, again, here we have an interesting workflow
dynamic where we're asked to save the description
for the break that we're editing.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Now, given the way that this
worked, as in I finished my break and then
straight away we were dumped into this edit
break, there is really no circumstance where
I wouldn't want to save what I've done.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: So you can probably get rid
of your save icon and just, and the trash
icon, and just basically allow you to hit
back or hit up and be done.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah and there's really two
problems here because even if you did determine
through, let's say, extensive user experience
testing that having a save button and a cancel
button was the right thing to do, there are
common icons for that.
There's a little check box meaning done
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: which implies saving and there's
an X meaning cancel.
So the little disc icon, although I do realize
that the floppy disc is a universal save symbol
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: We don't use it on Android;
we have our own set of icons.
>>Reto Meier: It's true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You should always use the
system icons wherever possible because that
will help, not only help your app be understandable
to users but help the entire eco system be
learnable.
>>Reto Meier: Indeed and one of the benefits
you get from using those system icons as well
is that everything will be sized and shaped
the same way and in the same style.
So looking at this, what I know to be a trash
icon because I'm expecting it to be a trash
icon, but could just as easily be a birthday
present.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Or a spaghetti pot.
>>Reto Meier: Or a spaghetti pot, yeah.
That's better, actually, with a slightly oversized
lid.
Yeah, so, you know, you don't want users to
have to try and interrupt what your glyphs
are.
You just want it to be straight forward and
you wanna get rid of them wherever you can.
So let's
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: What's on the, what's on the
overflow menu?
>>Reto Meier: I was wondering that myself.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know what, I like having
settings on the overflow menu and I, personally,
I don't think that everyone agrees with me
on this.
This is not a requirement.
I personally like having settings be pretty
much accessible everywhere.
>>Reto Meier: I kind of agree.
I think if you've got these, sort of, universal
applications like settings back up and the
support page, if you have them anywhere you
may as well have them everywhere.
I think that makes it easy.
You don't want to have to navigate your app
to figure out where you can get settings.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: I think that's reasonable.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But, let's see what happens,
okay, so
>>Reto Meier: Ah, canceled.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Again, we had three way, no,
four ways of leaving that particular activity.
One was the up affordance; the other was the
back key, are we calling the back an affordance
now?
>>Reto Meier: I think just the back key.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I'm not really sure what affordance
even means but it makes me sound really, really
smart.
>>Reto Meier: It does.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: It really does.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, the up affordance, the
vertical y axis positive affordance
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Took us back.
The back key, I would assume, probably would
also take us back.
>>Reto Meier: I would assume it does that
same thing.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then you've also got the
done and cancel, or save and cancel.
So four ways to exit that activity
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Not all of which were self
explanatory.
>>Reto Meier: No and all but one will actually
cancel what you were doing which seems counter
intuitive.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Which is weird.
>>Reto Meier: To be honest I'm a little stuck
now because I took a break, I ended the break
and then I had to describe the break but then
I canceled.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Didn't feel like describing
the break so I left
>>Reto Meier: but now did I not take a break?
Or do I just not have the break described?
I'm not sure.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think it depends on whether
this app has the power to manipulate time.
>>Reto Meier: Do you feel like you've had
a break?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No, I should probably have
another break.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
[Pause]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright, breaks over.
Back to work.
>>Reto Meier: Okay, so now I'm gonna hit save
this time.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Reto Meier: So that we go back.
Break successfully saved.
So, again, this is something which we talked
about last week and something that we've discussed
internally as a team is this notion of using
toasts to inform people when things happen.
And my feeling is this is kind of a developer
hack.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: it's the way that you say, "hey
I'm not entirely convinced that my code does
what I expect it to so every time I'm gonna
do something I'm gonna pop up a notification
telling me so that when I hit save I know
that my service has, in fact, kicked off and
saved it in the background.
"
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I mean, when you put
a toast in you're basically saying, "I have
something to say but it is completely unimportant."
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Exactly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Because if you miss it, I
don't care.
>>Reto Meier: So what you really wanna be
doing here is having the faith in your own
app.
So, by all means have toasts in the same way
that you have log statements so that when
you're doing your own testing, when you're
figuring out whether your workflows all work
and you're pressing the backs and the ups
and confirming what does what, that makes
total sense, but before you ship you should
probably be able to move pretty much all of
your toasts.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Most of them, I mean, there
certainly are times when I appreciate a toast
or two.
>>Reto Meier: Sure, first thing in the morning?
After a late night?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
>>Reto Meier: With a soft boiled egg?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
Well, poached usually.
>>Reto Meier: Poached, yeah that's nice, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But in this case I don't know.
One of the main issues that I have is that
this particular toast was telling me that
something that I've been working on was rejected
because I happened to hit the wrong button.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And in that case, to me, that's
not toast worthy.
That's more of a flashing, you know, drudge
report light saying
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, something has gone
seriously wrong.
But that's just me.
I mean, I don't, the main question is, did
I still take that break?
How would we find out?
>>Reto Meier: I don't know.
Let's have a look.
So I'm, looking at this I'm gonna go ahead
and assume that what we have done in the bottom
here is some sort of report.
That's not telling me much.
I'm gonna drop that back down.
Alright.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, well, what if we stop
working, would we be able to
>>Reto Meier: Well, let's stop working.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, alright
>>Reto Meier: Now it's asking us what work
have you done?
It's a fair question.
Hm, let's just, I have a suspicion that if
I hit back or up or anything other than save
then it's gonna lose the work that I've done.
We should have about 6 minutes of work there,
we hit save, we go in, task saved.
So we've got, let's have a look on breaks.
So it did both breaks of minus and minutes.
I think maybe it can manipulate time.
Oh.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That can't possibly be negative.
>>Reto Meier: I think what it's saying is
that, uh, so this is essentially like a double
accounting.
So this is minus a minute in that it's a minute
away from the total amount of time that we
spent.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right, right.
>>Reto Meier: So this makes sense.
But, in the way that it's described here it's
kind of backwards.
So I understand from your accounting perspective
that it represents a negative number but in
terms of breaks I'm looking at this going,
"How am I spending minus time on a break?"
So you should probably make sure that everything
is in the correct orientation, I guess, before
you do it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: What if we just say, well,
yeah see, you're right that it's very similar
to double accounting but the thing that makes
double accounting understandable is that there
are, in fact, two columns.
>>Reto Meier: Two columns.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: That's kind of the key.
So you can only really, it makes it appropriate
if you have sort of your work time and your
breaks next to each other, then it makes sense.
If not, as in here, it kind of doesn't.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: yeah, indeed.
>>Reto Meier: No expenses, no details etcetera.
So, I think the key piece of information from
what we've looked at here is really that you
want to make it obvious to the user what they're
actions are going to do.
So in this case, even though we hit cancel
and it said that the action in which we had
tried to perform had been canceled, it hadn't
been, right?
It's still here.
We still have the break which is, frankly,
what the user wants and expects so we're glad
that it does behave this way but don't tell
me that it's canceled if it's not canceled
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Really all you're saying here
is that you didn't put in a description.
And frankly, the use case where you're gonna
wanna go in there and type something and then
not keep whatever you've typed is pretty close
to zero, right?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, well, especially if
you have the ability to edit it afterwards.
>>Reto Meier: Precisely, so you can always
change it.
So really in that case it should only be,
there should only be one thing you can do
there which is basically edit that break which
is exactly what you're doing.
So you want to edit it and then return back
to where you were.
So you don't need, you don't need to confirm
save, you don't need to cancel, you don't
need to do anything other than be able to
exit back so it should really just, everything
should take you back one step and successfully
save.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, exactly.
>>Reto Meier: So the other thing, so if we
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, I wouldn't mind
also the ability to, I mean, if I'm gonna
keep track of breaks like that and if actually
want to fill in details which, by the way,
I don't.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I am so glad that I don't
work on a job that, where that is even remotely
necessary.
>>Reto Meier: This is true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But if I did I probably wouldn't
wanna type, I mean, what do I do?
Like, I went to get coffee, go to the bathroom,
you know, go smoke, buy drugs
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You know, any of these things
>>Reto Meier: Like more cigarettes, of course.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Or, I mean, this is the state
of California.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: That's very true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Point is, I have a limited
number of things.
I would like to have some defaults.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Yeah, defaults would be nice.
It'd be good if it remembers the sorts of
things you do on your break or even the work
tasks so you can select them.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That would be ideal, right?
Because you can just say, yeah, you know,
at 9 a.m.
I always have my coffee.
At 11:30 I kill someone, at noon I have lunch,
all these things
>>Reto Meier: Three o'clock hide the body.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: This is, I mean, so obviously
it would just be nice to remember an auto
fill.
If you want it to be really, really, really
special, you would keep track of those breaks
which do occur at the same time and say, "Ah,
Ian's taking a break at 9.
It's probably coffee, refill it with coffee
and you can always change it.
With most of these things it's gonna be the
same repetitive tasks over and over again,
particularly when it comes to breaks.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And this is what I noticed
about all time keeping tools cause I've seen
a lot of them, the simpler they are and the
less interaction they take, the better they
work.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So for instance, one of the
ultimate time keeping tools that I saw for
software engineering just keeps track of whether
you're typing or not.
>>Reto Meier: Nice, very simple.
I built a time keeping app myself and it was
exactly the same principle.
You don't want to have to do much.
Really, the only thing you wanna have to do
is say I'm switching to another task.
And frankly, you don't even necessarily even
want to have to say what that task is at the
time, you just wanna hit one button and be
able to move on with actual work cause every
time you're having to fill in the time sheet
you're not working.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
>>Reto Meier: Sadly, very few companies will
let you put time sheet management in your
time sheet as a task.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No, no, that would be--
>>Reto Meier: Which is unfortunate cause I,
there was a couple of jobs where I had to
fill out three different time sheets at half
hour intervals, so that was fun.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I haven't filled out a time
sheet since I was like 22.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Nice, nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But then again I never did
contract work.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
You never did contract work.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: that's probably where the
big backs are.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, in the finance industry
they care, they care a lot.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: They do, indeed.
>>Reto Meier: So we're not gonna spend too
much time on this one cause we've already,
I think, given most of the feedback but the
key thing I wanted to point out here is that
what do I do if I want to work on a different
project?
So you've got the, uh, you've got the Friday
games coming up later today, I'm gonna be
producing that as well, how do we set this
up so we can now get the time to a different
job.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, um, that?
>>Reto Meier: It is.
So you've discovered it which is nice.
Now, while we're going through this, what
I actually quite like here is that as you're
putting through all the details you can actually
hit this button and it'll figure out the office
details for you.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, that's nice.
>>Reto Meier: Which is quite nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Anything that makes--
>>Reto Meier: Well, yeah, but I'm gonna give
it that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: What it might also be even more
useful is to a geocoding reverse look up and
figure out what businesses are in the nearby
vicinity and let me choose from that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
That'd be really cool.
>>Reto Meier: Cause chances are I'm more interested
in the company than I am in the actual specific
location.
But, I wanted to highlight this, so now, see,
I guess my problem here is that this navigation,
so we are using this appropriately for navigation
but it's not immediately obvious that all
these other things exists.
And export and files don't really fit that
category; they should kind of, probably be
in the overflow menu as something you can
always get to.
So you're really only looking at time sheets
and projects.
So I would, I'm certainly not endorsing a--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: No, yeah
>>Reto Meier: So I'm certainly not endorsing
a dashboard patent but I think in this instance,
where you've got this sort of amount of space
here on your homepage effectively, it might
be useful to have a way, right here, of being
able to initiate that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And that's the thing, too.
Okay, I've got app clinic, I dropped that
down, I assumed that if I had more projects
that I'd have more in the dropdown.
The thing is, when I'm looking at this, that's
a natural time for me to be thinking, "Oh,
I need another one."
So I wouldn't mind having a--
>>Reto Meier: Right there, yeah.
New project.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Something in there.
Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: So I think it's reasonable to
have this here in the navigation by time sheets
and projects, but I think what you want here,
cause this is the screen, this is your main
screen.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Now what if I just hit the,
you know, there's a plus button there.
>>Reto Meier: There is a plus button.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's the wrong plus button
>>Reto Meier: It is.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's actually the Bayer Aspirin
button.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: It is the Bayer Aspirin button.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That's, uh, trademark infringement
all over the place.
So now I have, okay, add task.
Alright, I guess I was in the task view, is
that
>>Reto Meier: So I think the idea here is
that for every project you have tasks.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Reto Meier: So say you went and bought donuts
for the App Clinic, you would add that task
to this project.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That is a task that you consistently
fail at.
>>Reto Meier: Yes, it really is.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: So yeah, let's just have a quick
look.
You can add tags, working with me, none, fail
at that.
Location, feeling pretty sad about it, not
quite sure what the feeling is for but I kind
of like it.
And there's no way to, so there's no description
or anything else for the, for this task.
It's just basically the description, a summary.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: I hit save.
Again, it's not, it's not entirely clear what
that means.
So we go back here, it seems like I've gone
back twice.
Go to projects; see now the navigation is
broken.
I'm sort of like "Wait, I didn't navigate
that many parts in and this task that I just
saved where does it live?
What does it do?
Do I need to have been working in order to
create the task?"
So,
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: the way that all the things
join together; how do projects and tasks and
breaks and work, how does that all fit together?
It should be obvious.
I shouldn't have to figure it out because,
as Ian said, I don't wanna have to fill out
a time sheet to begin with.
I'm only doing this, either because my employer
requires it or because I need to be able to
keep track of who to bill.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: And so you wanna do as little
thinking as possible when it comes to filling
in that.
So you wanna have a really clear flow of navigation
through each of those tasks.
I think, as a homepage.
This is really nice and it shows you what
you're working on and sort of one click to
start which is great.
So, if you can have ways to link to new projects
and new tasks, as appropriately from that,
I think you're onto something.
And you also, I think, want to, you wanna
simplify this navigation.
So once you get into the project side it all
starts to get a little complicated with, so
here's the task.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: One thing I think that could
really just turn this into a winner is integration
with something in the Cloud.
Even just a simple, you know, say App engine
database.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: where I could bring this down
as a spreadsheet, edit it in let's say, Google
Docs or your favorite documentation tool and
be able to set some of this stuff up on the
computer where I've got a full size keyboard
and I don't mind doing some of this stuff.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
So that's something which when I was experimenting
with various Google APIs, before I joined
Google, I did exactly that.
So, it actually saved everything straight
into Google calendar so you could see exactly
what task you performed and there's a script
that ran on a server which paused the calendar
and created a Google Doc spreadsheet which
was the actual time sheet.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: That is really cool.
>>Reto Meier: Which was tidy and, you know,
I liked that because it meant that I could,
you know, record the information on my phone
but then when it came to actually saving it
and producing it and printing it out it was
all done, you know, in the Cloud.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Nice, I've never hooked anything
up to my Google calendar like that because
I think it would demonstrate exactly how much
of my time is wasted every single day.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's a little depressing,
really.
>>Reto Meier: It could be.
So, but anyway.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: It's just these two hours
a week that I get anything done.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Well at least you get those
two hours, that's important.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
>>Reto Meier: So yeah, I think that would
be the other piece of the functionality device
is definitely hook it up to the Cloud somehow.
It doesn't need to be through a Google specific
product but some way to know that what I've
entered in here is gonna be recorded and saved
somewhere, I think is really vital.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
So
>>Reto Meier: So, what else we got here?
Did we wanna have a quick look at Timesheets
on the tablet?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Sure.
>>Reto Meier: see if they've optimized for
tablets.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So they say they've got a
new design.
Ok, so this, in this case, well I haven't
set this up so it's asking me for a new project
which, again, will be our mobile
[Pause]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright, and, oh I guess I
have a save button here.
>>Reto Meier: okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, so that's--
>>Reto Meier: That's nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: that's actually a much more,
although--
>>Daniel Pham: Ian, can you jiggle the HDMI
cable a little bit?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
[Pause]
>>Reto Meier: Beautiful, here we go.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, but now I'm missing my,
I wanna, ah there we go.
>>Reto Meier: You gotta go back up.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I miss the little coffee cup
now.
>>Reto Meier: I do too.
Particularly because you've got all this white
space and you don't have the coffee cup.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And what I really want is
I want a big red start working button.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Wouldn't that be great?
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely and maybe even shaped
as, usually I don't suggest going away from
Android styling but an actual like big button
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Reto Meier: Would be kind of cool.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I would go for that, definitely.
>>Reto Meier: And let's just, you know, if
you have a look at--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: there's actually a really
good one on Istock photo, it costs like 7
bucks, I think you can probably afford it.
>>Reto Meier: I think it'd be worth it.
So, you know, in fact, I think in this particular
instance when you're working on tablet, this
is your view, right?
So I think you almost want to avoid having
that entire, you know, this view I think is
much less valuable.
You wanna basically start in projects and
then use your dropdown to navigate between
projects.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Same way which Gmail let's you
choose labels, so you're always looking at
this.
And I would have in, you know, in an extra
fragment somewhere in this zone.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
Now if I go to tasks here, the one thing that,
okay, so I do have an add new task action.
Now, just this, now this zero kind of in the
middle here is a little confusing to me
>>Reto Meier: Particularly, I think, cause
we had this nice style that we saw earlier
with the sort of cursively written hints,
that would be much nicer here.
You don't have any tasks, you know, click
the add tasks button to add something, I think
would really add.
[Pause]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright, here we go.
I think I may be a little, okay, you're right
I'm happy.
>>Reto Meier: You're happy now.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I'm reasonably happy.
You know, I don't like mint martinis as well
as beer.
>>Reto Meier: You'll be happier later then,
I guess.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
Okay, so, um, what'd I do?
>>Reto Meier: Ah, so now you're viewing the
task.
So this is a really interesting example of
why the navigation doesn't quite work.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Cause what you really want is
to tag this task view within this fragment
scenario.
So you basically wanna have this view.
You basically, on a tablet, you never wanna
be getting rid of this size, this side, that
should be your, kind of your control pad where
you choose your projects and that's where
you start working, have your breaks, everything
lives there and then the detail all comes
in on the right hand side.
So I'd say, you know, it seems like, that
their tablet layout is relatively new.
I would say you're on the right track, definitely
keep going along those lines but try and come
up with more ways to be able to really reduce
those, that navigation flow.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well let me emphasize this,
you are absolutely on the right track.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: You're doing everything right,
you're not doing anything stupid, there's
just a few things you could probably think
through how you could reduce the amount of
complexity in the app.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Reduce complexity, reduce the navigation,
I think if you stick anyone who knows vaguely,
you know, someone who uses time sheets but
has no idea about your app, sit them in front
of it and just watch them try and figure out
how to do things.
And every time they click something and then
go back and click something else, trying to
find it
[Audio/video skips ahead]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Something, but for finishing
it, for adding details, all of these things,
you know, maybe it really just needs to be
a completely separate flow.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
Let's move on.
We've still got a few more minutes.
Squeeze that across.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes.
>>Reto Meier: And let's have a look at Invoice2Go,
I think.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Reto Meier: So we're gonna have to breeze
through the next couple a little more quickly
than we have thus far.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Always happens, always happens.
>>Reto Meier: Always does.
We're gonna zoom in on the phone camera, I
can see it happening.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yes, it's gonna happen any
minute now.
>>Reto Meier: Any minute now.
Yes!
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: There we go.
>>Reto Meier: Look at that.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Alright.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Daniel Pham: Which app is this?
>>Reto Meier: This is Invoice2Go
>>Daniel Pham: This isn't right.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: What I think is interesting
is that the Invoice2Go action bar
>>Reto Meier: Now I'm just confused.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: This is really, really, weird
cause you'd think that if the title in the
action bar is Radioactive Yak and there is
a way to add multiple companies which, where
you might be switching between companies,
it seems like Radioactive Yak should be a
dropdown
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: On the left hand side which
is, of course, the
>>Reto Meier: So I would expect to
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So what happens if you add
another company?
>>Reto Meier: Let's have a look.
[Pause]
>>Reto Meier: Start a new company.
New company.
So this is the workflow when you begin.
So this is how you basically go through and
decide what the invoice is going to look like
for your company.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: There really are quite a few,
nice size.
>>Reto Meier: It's quite a nice, yeah, quite
a lot of nice ones.
Let's go with Fresh.
So we can choose all of our different fields,
it's not gonna go through all of these in
detail.
Company name, let's see, we'll go with the
App Clinic.
We need to give an address.
So, again, this may be a good opportunity
to figure that I'm putting in the details
where I currently am.
Let's have a look here, do I need all of them?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Oh, but you need 2 address
lines.
>>Reto Meier: Two address lines which is interesting.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Interesting.
The truth is that data validation when you're
enforcing business rules is important but
I think people take it too far.
I think that when you're writing something
that's, you know, gonna be handed off to a
data entry clerk it's nice to have some validation,
when you're doing the setup, however, maybe
not so much.
>>Reto Meier: It's my company, I get to decide
exactly how it should appear on the address
form.
So, yeah if, exactly.
So we're gonna skip all of these as well.
Minor point; you don't need the e.g. to propend
you just have the sample stuff and, in fact,
even the phone itself, fax etcetera, isn't
kind of the standard way you do hint text.
You wanna, yeah, you just wanna show what
they should be putting in there and let them
put it in there themselves.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So here you just have phone
instead of e.g. phone
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, or you would just have
the phone number.
Just say 555-5555
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Really?
>>Reto Meier: As an example.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Okay, that's fair.
>>Reto Meier: Certainly what you would do
for email and those sorts of things.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I guess so.
>>Reto Meier: This is interesting in that
we're not doing any validation on the cell
phone numbers.
Chances are you're only gonna use numbers
and maybe dashes, you wanna set the keyboard
type appropriately.
Set our tax rate.
Sure, and then we're done.
So now we're back in mash and, again, so now
if we wanna choose a different company then
we go through this.
So that's
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, that seems a little
unfortunate.
That's the action bar navigation is pretty
solid.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: People are gonna expect that.
>>Reto Meier: I think in this instance it
makes obvious sense, you know, if you have
the company name here you're gonna expect
that that dropdown is gonna let you choose
them.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
>>Reto Meier: Particularly as you go into
this action bar style.
Very quickly, I'll switch companies.
Otherwise this is kind of a dashboard patent
which, I guess, kind of makes sense in this
instance in that you're just trying to do
these particular things.
It doesn't really make sense to drop you into
any one of them independently.
But I wonder, how does this look on the, on
the tablet?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think they actually have
a pretty nice tablet layout.
It's, it's unconventional.
>>Reto Meier: This is actually quite different
from the phone.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Uh, yeah, it really is.
So, the, there's a couple things that I wanted
to point out.
First, the action bar, of course, is just
as useful as it was on the phone which is
to say
>>Reto Meier: Not particularly.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, not as much.
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then they have this area
over here on the left.
Now, that's really interesting to me.
It's unconventional, I don't dislike it, I
find it to be useful but there is actually
a pattern which we just added which is called
the, help me out here, the Drawer.
>>Reto Meier: The Drawer, absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: If you look for the Drawer
pattern, you've seen variations on this in
several apps; Facebook app had it, the Google
Plus app, the YouTube app
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: there were a lot of requests
for it to be added to the design patterns
so the design team sat down, looked at all
of the variations on this and sort of tried
to figure out which ones were most effective
and most like other Android patterns.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, what we settled on is
something you can slide this in and out.
Usually you don't just see icons.
Usually you'll see icons and such.
It should always be under the action bar,
never over the top and never pushes the action
bar over.
>>Reto Meier: That's right.
Action bar is a first class citizen.
It's always there; it stays at the top of
your app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Consistently.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And, point of fact, I think
it was YouTube that was actually implementing
all of our suggestions.
>>Reto Meier: Right, I think all of the examples
on the design sites use YouTube.
So, if you're wondering how should it work,
how should it look in practice, I would definitely
check out the latest YouTube app.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
So this is very, very close to the Drawer
pattern and the Drawer pattern is basically
saying I have a fairly complicated bit of
navigation, more than is sensible for the
dropdown area
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And so, I don't want it to
always necessarily be visible.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I think I would switch to
that.
Now, over here in the main area we've got
the original sort of dashboard idea and then
some extra stuff.
I don't hate it but I, I can't rationally
defend it either.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: It does look like what can we
put here to fill up some space?
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, I'm not sure what the
right solution is.
I wonder if there are shortcuts
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I mean, if we go to an invoice,
right, uh, right now I'm kind of bugged by
this because now it's using the entire screen
and I kinda would like to still have some,
you know,
>>Reto Meier: Some navigation.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You know, maybe even just, you know, and this
is all create.
You know, maybe what I would like is to see,
oh, so that's my product view, I guess?
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: This, okay, now this is what
I want.
Okay, I've got invoices and add invoice.
And to me, A, I don't want to go to this screen.
I want the add invoice activity to be a fragment
inside here.
I think that makes a ton more sense.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I would like the invoices
to be listed over on the left whereas right
now I think this is more, you know, most likely
the list, right?
>>Reto Meier: I think it's gonna be all of
your invoices, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I think that, that's really
what we've been getting at is, in general,
this is, you know, I would call this like
the Windows Explorer or Finder type of view
on something where you've got this sort of
folder idea over on the left and then a list
view on the right and that, that almost never
feels right to me.
>>Reto Meier: No, it's not, it's not quite
right.
I don't know, not on a mobile device, on a
phone or a tablet, where you don't wanna have
to navigate, you don't wanna have to think
about things being in this hierarchical folder
structure.
There's really no reason why you can't, sort
of, have everything kind of on the left.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
Especially since they've already gone hierarchical
with this so it wouldn't be that hard to just
say, "Okay, I'm gonna open up my invoices
and see them listed underneath invoices and
then I could see the invoice details over
on the right.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, just have a big plus icon
next to each of the categories so you can
add any new invoice, new estimate, purchase
order etcetera.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I think I would probably
prefer that.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
So, again, it's basically the same sort of
story that we've been saying all the time
which is to simplify your navigation as much
as possible.
You don't want to have, every time you change
the entire screen, you're changing the context
in which you're working which means you need
to take a few seconds to figure out what just
happened, where am I?
what do I have to do?
The list you can do that--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: This is something that actually,
you know, they've done cognitive studies where
when you chance context it's the habit of
your brain to actually forget what you were
doing.
It's why, and they've shown this like every
time you go through a door, for instance.
>>Reto Meier: I've seen this, yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So this is why you go into
another room and then ask yourself, "Why am
I here?"
Now, I do that because I'm old
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But other people do that because
of this cognitive thing.
>>Reto Meier: You just forget, you walked
through.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, yeah, every time you switch
something completely and I think that's really
what I'm getting at, right?
It's not that I don't like the layout here,
it's not that I strongly object, it's just
the fact that to get anything done, to see
anything useful I have to pick something that
is gonna take me to a completely new area,
right?
Some of these are worse than others, you know?
So to view an invoice, you know, it sort of
took me over to the right where now I've got
this list view here.
So I don't hate that as much, but to add an
invoice--
>>Reto Meier: It's a completely new screen.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, completely new screen.
>>Reto Meier: And definitely not tablet optimized,
either.
You know, for something like this, oh, it
is confusing.
Add invoice, so for something like this where
you've got a huge amount of white space, now
obviously once you've got the icons that may
change, but it may not even be a bad thing
here to actually have the white space around
the borders rather than in the middle of your
screen cause this part here in the middle,
this is where you actually are gonna be paying
attention, that's where the user is gonna
be looking.
But all the important stuff is on the edges.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So I think if I had to choose
the most Androidy way to do this it would
probably be to have this left hand navigation
area be expressed as either action bar navigation
or a view pager.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah, a view pager actually
would be quite nice, I think.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: So, flip between them and you
don't actually need to see them next to each
other.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, we never even see this;
instead we always see this view.
So we have the view of the, you know, the
master view here, we have a detail view here
that's actually a detail view instead of another
master view.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And then I could, you know,
page through either by dropping down or doing
some paging here or using the drawer, I mean,
there's any number of ways that I could do
that.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
I think it'd be quite--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But I wouldn't waste this
kind of space on what's essentially a navigation
field.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah because keep in mind, as
well, that these things don't actually have
anything in common.
The commonality is that they're all pieces
of paper that you have to generate business
to either charge someone, pay someone or be
paid.
But having them listed here sort of implies
a hierarchy that doesn't really exist.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Not so much, yeah.
>>Reto Meier: So just having them separated
by navigation or I quite like the idea of
having the view pager so you scroll between
your invoices and your estimates.
It's not a huge number so it doesn't become
unwieldy or hard to find.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: But yeah, that's your call,
something to experiment with perhaps but that's
what I'd consider.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Great.
So I think we've, we've offered a lot of constructive
feedback on apps that we thought were really
quite good.
Um, there are a few apps that we don't have
time to look at in exhausted detail; quite
honestly I didn't think that they were quite
as good.
One is Financiso
>>Reto Meier: I struggled with this one so
I'm looking this up and pretty quickly turned
it back off because I really didn't understand
what I was supposed to do with it.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I'm not sure.
Now, maybe if I was considerably more wealthy
because I did notice that I have the ability
to do all sorts of things in this application
in any currency I want.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Something like 200 built in
currencies and including special drawing rights
which who has those, right?
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right and I can also use my
own made up currency.
>>Reto Meier: That's handy.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So, with my own symbol and
everything.
So I made up the Twitter bucks with, of course,
the at sign as the symbol.
>>Reto Meier: Nice.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Because it's Ian I was expecting
Ni-Lewis bucks.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well, no, it didn't make nearly
as much sense.
So, and that, of course, is what I'm paying
my minions.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: Excellent.
That's interesting.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But this kind of surprised
me, too.
Like I can see that I can add budget items
but as far as I can tell each budget is partly
red and partly green for no apparent reason.
I'm really, really not understanding that.
>>Reto Meier: It seems like it's just there
to--
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: And I haven't paid it because
I don't have a transaction, maybe?
In other words, there's, this is one of those
things where there's obviously a lot of power
>>Reto Meier Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But it makes no sense.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
It fails the I just installed this app how
do I get started test.
And I can't see, when I start this app I don't
see, what is the value?
What can I do?
What is it giving me that some other app hasn't?
So I just downloaded a bunch of budgeting
apps then I'm kind of stuck here cause I loaded
up and if we switch to the phone view, I haven't
put anything into this one yet so we should
be able to fire it up.
[Pause]
>>Reto Meier: And this is kind of what you're
presented with at start up and it's kind of,
it's the old school model so it's a gingerbread
type tabs and buttons and everything else
which is already a bit off putting.
There's no title bar or action bar so, again,
there's no context hint as to what am I doing?
How am I supposed to do things?
And it just says you should get started by
creating an account by hitting a plus.
And then title which doesn't quite make sense
my accounts have titles, I guess.
It feels like it should be name or description
or something.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well that's a minor thing.
>>Reto Meier: It is a minor thing but it goes
to the whole flow of being like I'm not quite
sure what they want or what this is for or
how this is gonna help me.
Compare that to the other apps we've looked
at, it became pretty obvious straight away,
like, okay so this is for creating invoices,
first thing I do is choose what the invoice
looks like and then you understand right off
the bat that, okay this is probably gonna
create invoices for me.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: My major objection to this
is that with the state of things now, I'm
much more likely to do something that can
hook into my actual bank account because all
my things are done electronically and I think
that's why I gravitate to something like Mint.com.
Alright, we're just about out of time but
one app that we didn't really look at was
IOU.
The truth is, IOU is, you know, gonna be honest.
I was never a huge fan of holo.
>>Reto Meier: Okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: From the beginning I said
to myself it's interesting that we all wanna
be like holographic and electronic style but
I don't personally like it.
So, with that in mind,
>>Reto Meier: Okay.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: what I'm about to say may
be complete, just a complete personal problem
but I find this black screen to be off putting.
>>Reto Meier: Well I think, you know, it'd
be helpful if we had Roman here to confirm
but I think in general we found that for most
sort of data entry things, anything other
than media, the hollow light theme is sort
of more visually pleasing.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Reto Meier: The white backgrounds and white
action bar rather than dark.
Dark works well for things like YouTube, for
video playing
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: There you go.
>>Reto Meier: Anywhere there's sort of the
content is front and center and what you're
looking at is really important so you want
everything else to just sort of fade into
the background.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Well I think we can just say
there's a rule of thumb here is if you're
going to be using this app while wearing your
little black dress then it should be holo
dark and if you're going to be wearing it
wearing your white shirt and tie then it should
be holo white.
>>Reto Meier: I think that's something everyone
should find very useful.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Especially those who wear both a shirt and
tie and a little black dress.
>>Reto Meier: And a little black dress.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Maybe this is
>>Reto Meier: I thought we weren't gonna talk
about this on air.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Reto Meier: Moving on.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Really unique.
So we, we don't have time to discuss it more,
it does actually seem like it's got some nice
functionality and we might wanna cover it
more
>>Reto Meier: And look, generally speaking
it keeps things simple, it's obvious what
it's for, not overly complicated navigation
so they do a few things right.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
It's nice that you can
>>Reto Meier: It would be nice if that was
a view pager so you can slide between
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: between them
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: yeah, right now I'm wondering
why can't I slide between them.
Alright.
So, and that falls into the bucket that we
talked about earlier which is if you make
something that looks like a standard Android
UI element, you know, if you have to implement
your own, if you want to implement your own,
bravo to you, you're completely wasting your
time,
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But if you do, make sure it
operates in exactly the same way because otherwise
people will just be frustrated.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I mean, honestly, it's like
getting into a car and finding out that the
brakes on the right and gas is on the left.
[Laughter]
>>Reto Meier: That's not gonna end well.
I had a problem; I came to the US, opened
the car and found the entire steering assembler
was on the wrong side of the car.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Yeah, well it's, you know,
when you come to a different operating system,
let's say,
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: you often
>>Reto Meier: You need to adapt.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: But I think you probably will
have noticed that every car in the United
States drives that way.
>>Reto Meier: It's true.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: So even though it may appear
completely wrong, consistency is a virtue.
>>Reto Meier: Absolutely.
As they say, adapt or die, in some cases a
little more literally than others.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
Alright, that's all we have time for today,
folks.
So thank you very much for joining us.
Let us know on our Google Plus page what you
think of today's show.
If you'd like us to, I don't know, bring back
the hangouts or switch microphones again
[Laughter]
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: or anything else let us know
what you think and until next week I'm Ian
Ni-Lewis.
>>Reto Meier: I'm Reto Meier and we'll see
you guys later.
In fact, we'll see you next week for music
players, I think.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: I believe it is.
>>Reto Meier: Yeah.
Music players, that should be a really interesting
show.
And, uh, yeah, see ya next week.
[Glasses clinking]